-My first guest is
a very talented actor
that you know from his work in
the Marvel cinematic universe.
His new film,
"Outside the Wire,"
begins streaming tomorrow
on Netflix.
Here he is, Anthony Mackie!
Look at this.
-What's up, man?
-We got a lot
to talk about, buddy,
but, first,
I want to say congratulations,
because you're the biggest
New Orleans Saints fan
that I know, and the Saints had
a big playoff win last week.
-Huge win. Huge.
Now we get our
division rival, Tampa Bay.
-What's it like watching
the game with you,
with Anthony Mackie?
-You know what?
It's a hard ride to roll.
-Yeah.
-You know, it's a lot of
talking, a lot of screaming,
a lot of throwing stuff, a lot
of drinks, a lot of hugging,
a lot of crying.
It's an emotional ride.
-Are you a superstitious fan?
Do you have to do anything,
like, in order or anything?
-I'm very superstitious.
So, you know,
the game comes on noon here,
1:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time,
and so I have to, you know,
get everything ready.
I have my collective jerseys
in order of strength,
like, the strongest being
my 12-year-old jersey,
the weakest being my 1-year-old
jersey, and so on and so forth.
And every other year,
I get a jersey.
So, you know,
I have my slippers, my socks,
my sweatshirt if I really need,
like, a strong pull.
So, you know,
I'm very superstitious.
I have to wear my
Saints slippers and socks
every day when I'm home.
-For how long? Since when?
When you were a kid?
-No, since we won
the Super Bowl, man,
Super Bowl XLIV.
-That changed it.
-Obama was the 44th president.
You play craps, 44.
Hard 8. 44, baby.
-[ Laughs ] Hard 8.
Oh, my gosh.
This weekend, though,
Saints going up against
Tom Brady.
-Yeah, man, yeah.
-How do you feel?
-I have an issue with -- I mean,
look, I hate Tom Brady, man.
I hated him when
he was with New England.
Tom Brady is one of those people
I know I'm going to
love him so much
that I hate him,
so I can never meet him,
because I just want to
hang out with him
and hug him and, like,
comb his hair
and cook him dinner.
Like, I just want to, like,
hang in a hot tub with Tom Brady
and talk about fun stuff.
-Yeah, he is cool.
He is too cool, man.
He's too perfect.
You go, "Yeah,
there's got to be something up."
-Yeah, he's like a Shih Tzu.
Like, he's so beautiful,
you just want to, you know,
shake him a little bit.
-You do, but, also,
he gets into those situations.
You go, "Well, he can't do that.
I mean, they're down,
you know, 30 points."
And he goes...
And you go, "Okay, come on."
Why would I say that?
-And he does it every time,
so to build up my power,
I wear my slippers,
my Saints slippers,
and my socks,
my Saints socks.
See what I'm saying?
I got wear them every day
up until the game,
for the whole week.
-Oh, do you really?
You take it that far?
-Yeah, you got build up
the power.
-[ Laughs ] Dude, good.
Now I'm rooting for them.
I hope they win, bud.
-They got to. They got to.
-I'm glad they're doing well,
because I've read
that you're in
this "Avengers"-only
fantasy-football league,
and your team did not
do so well this --
You finished second to last.
It's out.
People are talking about it.
Chris Pratt ended up
winning this year.
It's the headline of
every newspaper.
Which of the Avengers is
the biggest trash talker
when it comes to
fantasy football?
-It's a split.
I mean, Chris Evans
talks a lot of trash.
Paul Rudd talks
intellectual trash,
which is confusing,
because you don't know
if he's insulting you,
but you feel like
it's a dis somewhere in there.
So he's the guy
you want to fight.
You know, you can
talk back to Chris,
but Paul, it's like, "Nah."
-Yeah, you get it like
three days later.
You go, "Hey, that was insane.
That was like
four levels of insult."
-Or by the time you Google
all the words in his insult,
it's too late.
-The game's over. Yeah, exactly.
Hey, I want to talk about your
new movie, "Outside the Wire."
-Yeah.
Yeah, I'm excited about it.
-It's great.
There's action. There's robots.
There's a twist.
It's a good script.
I mean,
can you set up the movie?
-"Outside the Wire"
is a story of two soldiers
that go out
and try to stop a bad guy
from getting nukes to destroy
America and take over the world.
I play a cyborg,
and we have Damson Idris,
who comes in,
who is a drone pilot,
and I enlist him to help me and
go out and save the world.
-You did a lot of
stunts in this movie,
and you were telling me,
I mean, you're jumping off
buildings, explosions.
It's everywhere.
But you were telling me
your stuntman
actually got hurt
the first week of shooting,
so you kind of did
a lot of your own stunts.
Talk to me about this.
-Dude, first day, first stunt,
my stuntman
was supposed to chase
a dude through a market,
tackle him over a table.
So he tackles him,
hits his head on the ground.
He's concussed, out, like that.
And for some reason, summer of
2018 was a very good summer
for black stuntmen, because
we couldn't find another dude
to come in and do my stunts.
So my director, Mikael --
he calls me over
and he's like, "Okay, Anthony,
you know, you're big guy.
You go to gym, right?
People like you.
You big guy. Come on.
Jump off the building."
And I'm like, "What?"
He goes, "Come on, big guy."
Come on."
-"Big guy. Big guy, come on."
Dude, so that was you.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
-Yeah.
-Now I got to
rewatch it again, man.
It's a pretty intense movie.
I heard that something you do
after a long day of shooting,
to relax, you watch reruns of
"The Golden Girls."
Is this true?
-Yeah. Very true.
Hallmark has
the best TV programming
from 9:00 p.m. to 2:30 a.m.,
and they show about eight
episodes of "The Golden Girls,"
and they follow it up
with "Frasier."
And If you don't know me, I am a
"Golden Girl" kind of guy.
-Man, they can land
a joke, huh?
-Oh, they kill it. They kill it.
It's funny,
when you look at them,
the level of talent,
comedic and dramatic, they have.
I mean, if you look at --
You know, Betty White is one of
the most talented women.
She had her own talk show.
She, like -- She was a
professional dancer, actress.
She was amazing.
Those four women were amazing.
-Did you ever meet Betty White?
-[ Laughs ]
I met her once.
I was in New York at this event,
and she was there.
And, you know, I fan-boyed out
and ran up to her
and was like, "Oh, my God.
I love you so much.
I'm such a fan.
Like, the episode when you were
tap-dancing was so beautiful."
So she laughed and touched
my face and she says,
"Oh, you make me wish
I was 40 years younger."
And I was like...
-What?!
-I would do that.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-I would do that.
Well, dude, you're so great
in this movie,
so whatever "The Golden Girls"
did for you, it worked.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's our pal Anthony Mackie in
"Outside the Wire" on Netflix.
Take a look.
-Dress lieutenant.
Double time.
-What's this?
-You wear
your uniform out there,
you'll be a standing target.
-Thought I'd be guarding
a fence, sir.
-[ Chuckles ]
-I don't have any specialist
training as a field agent.
-Don't worry.
I'm special enough
for both of us.
♪♪
-You're a --
-Your commanding officer.
Fourth-generation biotech,
and I'm giving you
60 seconds to deal with it.
-When we come
back, Anthony Mackie and I
are going head-to-head in
a game of "Hey Robot."
Stick around.